it's not a great thing to work on your
birthday but if I have to sit in the
room with you - oh my birthday EXO is
your perfect your birthday was just two
weeks ago right my birthday is you know
what's the day yeah Friday right what's
today 15 oh yeah two days so this TV box
already feel like the day is young so I
still can't go celebrate what did you do
on your birthday
oh man said you know some scriptures but
if you get to celebrate Screen Actors
Guild nomination how'd that feel the
first one like 15 years right well I
said credit the man next to me who gave
me the opportunity to be in this film
and I left him a personal message but it
means a lot in this business to have
someone look out for your artistic
integrity yeah and I say it's it's a
team once I want to save you Michael
like I commend you the past few years
like as you've risen I love how you're
so conscious of reaching back and
bringing people with you like here with
your charity work with your in the
mystery liquid the inclusion writer like
why is that been such an important thing
for you to bring people with you as you
rise I'm after all a you know
[Music]
I'll see any other way to do it you know
I think I think this is kind of who I am
I was raised I think you know what I
feel like it's important how do I feel
you know the way I wants to be alone
yeah mmm you know saying like that in a
sense of I mean I'm blessed I know that
you know I've worked hard you know but I
know you know a lot of things I can't
take credit for and I feel like you know
you know I don't want to be an anomaly I
don't want to be the only I want I want
I want I want to have you know I take
joy and pride and and building things
and putting people together and letting
people see what I see you know and and
and people I admire and and and and you
know and and I've been disruptive yeah
you know there's a lot of things there's
a lot of systems and stuff that are
outdated and broken you know and I want
to be a part of the fix I wanna be a
part of the change it's just you know if
whatever I could doing this in his
lifetime you know I try to do it yeah
that's what I feel like it's kind of the
message of the movie a little bit like
it's heavy subject matter but it's a
very hopeful story what do you want my
name is to get out of this like it's not
just yeah prison for death row prisoner
I know what it is is that there's a man
out there who's working hard yeah that's
that's who this man embodies is a man
out there who understand how dire the
situation can be but if you listen to
them as in listening to Brian they talk
with hope they don't talk with like the
the worldís you know it was on fire in
some letter the passion is on fire to
get things right yeah
do you think things have changed like
since it's happened like that 10 is to
1993 no 27 years later to think this
change they lived there was a situation
it was just in Texas yeah you know it's
a is it because it again it happens
outside of you like we don't hit you you
didn't hear about these things you
didn't hear about that until 60 minutes
did it right but now we have the villain
option you know so it shows you did it
still that yeah congratulations it's a
yes that's very much thank you thank you